in my last video i took a look at a
document which showed some of the math
that
terence tau could do when he was seven
years old
but there was one page i didn't show you
and that's this one
a list of some of the books that terence
had read as a child
these books are from a longer list of 22
that terence had read by the time he was
eight
it says that he liked to read entire
books
and that he was keen for advice on what
to read next
it also says that he had a remarkable
memory for
things that he read terence is now a
professor of math at ucla
and he's 46 so some of these books are
fairly old but i managed to find some of
them at the library
i've got flatland by edwin abbott
i've got the elements of logic by
s barker and i've got calculus pure and
applied by
sherlock and i thought just out of
curiosity i'd take a look at what these
books are like
before i get stuck into them i will say
these books contain
hard stuff the textbooks are university
level
and the idea that an eight-year-old
would read them doesn't even really
make sense to me but it's true that most
of us
weren't given these books as
eight-year-olds so we will never really
know if we could have read them
of course young terence was lucky that
his family was able to support his
talents
i believe that genius is not just a
function of your mind
but also your environment but that
shouldn't take away
from how impressive terence is to have
the concentration and discipline
to finish these books at any age is
awesome
even with the incentive of filming this
video
i have probably spent more time on
tiktok than i have reading these books
over the past week
and for that i do look up to the
enthusiasm of an eight-year-old
flatland is the only one of the books
that i had read already
and unlike the others which are
textbooks this one is fiction
it's a story about shapes which i love i
think it's clever
insightful and it made me think about
dimensions in a way i never had before
but honestly i didn't love everything
about it
there are some parts that i found hard
to read because of the social commentary
about
gender and class that just doesn't land
well today
the story is set on a two-dimensional
plane and the narrator
a self-described gentleman is a square
shapes with more sides are higher in
class
hexagons are noble and something with
more sides than that
will approach the priestly order lower
class workmen
such as squares butler are triangles
women are a single straight line
there's his wife right there square's
house
is a pentagon but this top down view is
not how he sees it
to him all things look like lines of
varying size
but he can feel the vertices and
determine the angle
square visits line land which is only
one dimensional
and wishes that he could communicate to
the inhabitants
that there is a second dimension out
there but when square
is visited in flatland by a sphere from
a third dimension
square finds it hard to accept because
he can't imagine a third dimension
square wonders if this is true then what
would come next
and asks sphere if there is a fourth
dimension
sphere says no that's ridiculous
but really they're having the same
problem as square
they simply cannot imagine a dimension
above their own
overall it's a worthwhile mind bender
and it shows that even a book about math
can't be totally separated from the
culture
in which it was written moving on to
calculus
this is what seems like a fairly
standard calculus textbook
the first line of it is any situation
involving a rate of change is described
mathematically
in the language of calculus it starts
with the idea of a gradient
then works through differentiation areas
under a curve
and integration then we've got circular
functions motion
curves and parametric equations
a visit to infinite series and
exponentials and logarithms there's also
differential equations
hyperbolic functions and curves and
surfaces
some of the stuff i met at the end of
high school
or at university and much of it i've
forgotten
i've slept on my integration so long i
can barely do the basics
so this book would do me well as a
refresher
it seems clear enough although from what
i can see
it doesn't always explain too much of
the why
behind some of the definitions it gives
revision questions
after every few chapters with answers
which i like
someone who checked this out in the past
maybe this year or maybe 39 years ago
when it was published
has made a lot of annotations in pencil
i find these comforting
amongst all the seriousness of the math
there's
a human reminder and a source of company
it's a reminder as i try to decipher
each example
that i'm not the only one who's been
here they even left
a little to-do list saturday arvo read
notes
this book would have just been published
when terence read it
which is maybe why he picked it it is my
opinion that when it comes to
introductory calculus textbooks
they all pretty much cover the same sort
of stuff so
if your goal is to learn calculus then
the best book for you
is probably just the one that you have
access to
or it might be worth checking out a few
sample pages from a few options
to see which of the explanations you
prefer
on young terence's reading list there is
also
matrices and vectors numbers
inequalities and linear programming
readings in mathematics
and i found this picture of him reading
continued fractions
by olds at age nine also on the list
is the international mathematics
olympiad a book of past problems
and this is interesting because terence
would go on to become the youngest
competitor in this olympiad
at age 10. he won a bronze silver and
then a gold medal at age 13
making him the youngest winner of each
of these categories
and his two brothers nigel and trevor
have also represented australia
at this competition this next one is the
elements of logic
and it's got a pretty nice cover it goes
through an introduction to logic
as a means to make deductive and
inductive arguments
to understand truth functions
translating words into symbols
fallacies and applications to philosophy
it says that logic can be intellectually
rewarding
as knowledge for its own sake but it is
also practical
in helping us to become more effective
in recognizing and avoiding mistakes and
reasoning
and a person who can recognize and avoid
these logical mistakes in reasoning
will be able to think more clearly and
correctly and
more soundly and surely regardless of
what subject
they're thinking about if you are
wondering what logic has to do with
philosophy
then consider some of the questions of
philosophy
like what is the difference between good
and evil
is it possible to have knowledge and
can we ever prove that a thing is
beautiful
well logic also deals with very general
questions
like what good reasoning is and the
difference between correct and incorrect
steps in thinking
and in both philosophy and logic no
experiments are necessary
before we can consider what is good and
bad reasoning
we need to consider what reasoning
itself is
and it says here that reasoning is
starting with certain statements that
you assume to be true
then in thinking moving on to a
consequence that you think follows from
them
so what we're doing is making an
inference
constructing an argument and trying to
give a proof
what we start with are called premises
and what we reach at the end
is the conclusion and the book goes on
to explore
all the different forms of reasoning
we start to see some symbols here with
truth tables
this line means not and this little v
means or so for example in the top line
if p is true and q is true then p
and q has to be true but not
p and q would have to be false not p
is false not q is false not p
and not q is false and not p
or not q is also false
and from there we work up to the
elementary form of a valid argument
each line here represents a step of
logic
that we can use to construct an argument
this first bit is read if p then
q so if p is true therefore
q is true kind of like when we're doing
algebra we can replace something with an
equivalent form
we can do that here with logical
expressions
these are a list of statements that are
equivalent to each other
so we can put it all together in an
example like this one here
we start with these first three premises
we then make a series of logical
arguments
and end with forming a conclusion this
book was written in 1965
and there is one application of logic
that isn't mentioned
but is now central to modern computing
and that is logic gates this part of the
video is sponsored by brilliant
i'm going to work through their quiz on
logic gates to see how they work
we see the symbols for and or
and not and we can see what these basic
gates would look like
and outputs a one if both inputs are one
or outputs are one if at least one input
is one
not can change a 1 to a 0 or a 0 to a 1.
to combine these into a circuit means we
can chain
a logical expression the circuit here
represents
a and not b
or not a and
b we're asked what the output of this
circuit will be
and let's go through it this first gate
will output a one
since both inputs are one that one will
be combined with
a zero as input into the second and
and that would output a zero since an
and
requires that both inputs are one for
the output to be one
circuits like logical expressions can be
equivalent
for example these two circuits are
equivalent
as two consecutive not gates have no
effect
and this is especially important for
circuits as we generally want to build
ones that are as small as possible
combining logic gates we can perform all
sorts of operations
including things like the addition of
numbers if you would like to continue
this course yourself
you can head to brilliant.org tibees
and that link will be down in the
description below thank you to my
patreon supporters for
making these videos possible and a
special shout out
to today's patreon cat of the day
feldman
thanks for watching